[Music]
hi
my name is jaya ballou i'm the chief
information security officer
at avast and i'm also the quantum
ambassador
at kpn to introduce the european quantum
flagship in a few sentences would be to
explain
a massive project from the perspective
of the european union
we only have three flagships the human
brain
flagship the graphene flagship for new
materials for graphene
and now we have the quantum flagship and
the flagship
is investing a billion
euros in quantum research it's going on
for a period of
over 10 years there's more than 5 000
researchers and members of the academic
and commercial community that come
together
in order to realize quantum innovation
and development for european prosperity
and
jobs and our future so the main
objective of the european quantum
flagship is to have
innovation and research which propels
europe to be one of the top two
in the world in terms of having
innovation
for all of the quantum technologies from
computing
computation simulation and sensing and
meteorology
and this we believe will be the future
technology
that will propel us uh as humans
to embrace new advancements in science
so european quantum week runs from
november 2nd to the 6th it's running in
parallel with berlin science week
and basically it'll present all of the
work that we've been doing
on the quantum flagship in europe but
it'll also be
full of discussions both from an
academic level but also to community and
outreach so that it's also accessible
to not only scientists but more people
and talking about innovation and
development
and accessibility uh for educational
purposes
of all of the work around in quantum
that's what i find so inspiring
it's um it's this ability to do
something meaningful
that will help every european citizen
with underlying scientific breakthroughs
i think the there are a number of
unsolved questions and big challenges in
the field
and they're in you know the areas of
scientific challenges uh but they're
also engineering
uh challenges um for example uh for
developing a quantum computer we need to
fix issues with deco here and so that we
can have lots of qubits and
that it's still stable
and there's also questions around
society
how can we embrace all of the good
things that quantum computing will give
us
while understanding and mitigating any
potential downfalls
around for example cryptography which we
use every day all over the internet
so all of these challenges are
significant but i'm confident because of
the excellence
of research we have in europe will be
able to overcome them
i believe that the work that's being
done in europe around quantum
technologies
will change the world quantum
technologies are
fundamental for us to be able to better
understand
our universe they could help us
potentially solve
climate challenges that we're dealing
with now but also
covet 19 related challenges in terms of
drug development
quantum technologies can also be used to
improve
drug development and delivery so i
think that these things just those
things if the promise of quantum
computing comes true
it will radically change our planet